you've
mentioned that uh what you call
it kakina yeah yeah so you've mentioned
that a a chemical brain is something
you're interesting
creating and uh that's a way to get
conscious AI
soon can you explain what a chemical
brain is I want to understand the
mechanism of intelligence that's gone
through Evolution right cuz the way that
the way that um
intelligence was produced by Evolution
appears to be the following origin of
Life
multicellularity
Locomotion senses once you can start to
see things come coming toward you and
you can remember the past and
interrogate the present and imagine the
future you can do something amazing
right so and I think only in recent
years did humans become Che and
complete right yeah yeah yeah right
we'll get and so that true
incompleteness kind of gave us another
kick up um but our ability to process
that
information um as produced in a wet
brain and and I think that we are not
getting going to we do not have the
correct Hardware architectures to have
the domain flexibility and the inte the
ability to integrate information and I
think
intelligence um also comes at a massive
compromise of data right now we're
obsessing about getting more and more
data more and more processing more and
more tricks to get dopamine hits so
we're g to when we look back on this
going oh yeah that was really cool
because when I chat asked chat GPT it
made me it made me really feel really
happy I got a hit from it but actually
it just exposed how little intelligence
I use in a in every
moment because I'm easily F so what I
would like to do is to say well hey hang
on what is it about the brain so the
brain has this incredible connectivity
and it has the ability to um you know as
I said earlier about my nephew you know
I just I went from Bill to Billy and he
went H right Leroy like how did he make
that leap that he was able to basically
without any training I extended his name
he went G he doesn't like he wants to be
called Bill he went back and said you
like to be called Lee I'm going to call
you Leroy
um so human beings have a ma brilliant
ability or intelligent beings appear to
have a brilliant ability to integrate
across all domains all at once and to
synthesize something which allows us to
generate knowledge and and becoming true
and
complete on our own I don't although AI
are built in true incomplete things
their their thinking is not true
incomplete in that they are not able to
build Universal
explanations and that lack of universal
explanation means that they're just
inductivist inductivism doesn't get you
anywhere in not not it's just basically
a party trick it's like you know the the
I like the um I think it's in the fabric
of reality from David Deutsch where
basically you know the farmer is feeding
the chicken every day and the chicken's
getting fat and happy and the chicken's
like I'm really happy every time the
farmer comes in and fees me and then one
day the farmer comes in and
instead of feeding the chicken just
Rings its
neck you know and that's kind of and had
the chicken had an alternative
understanding of why the farmer was
feeding it m it's interesting though
because we don't know what's special
about the human mind that's able to come
up with these kind of
generalities uh this Universal theories
of things and come up with novelty I can
imagine cuz you gave an example you you
know about uh William and Leroy
I I feel like
example like that will be able to see in
future versions of a large language
models will be really really really
impressed by the humor the
insights all of it because it's
fundamentally trained on all the
incredible humor and insights that's
available out there on the internet
right so we'll be impressed I think
we'll be impressed oh I'm impressed
right I'm impressed increasingly so but
we're mining the past yes and what the
human brain appears to be able to do is
mine the future yes so novelty it is
interesting whether these large language
models will ever be able to come up with
something truly novel I can show on the
back of a piece of paper why that's
impossible and it's like the problem is
that and again these are domain experts
kind of bullshitting each other the term
generative yes right average person
think oh it's gener no no no if look
look if I take the the numbers between 0
and 1,000 and I train a model to pick
out the prime numbers by giving them all
the prime numbers between zero and a th
it doesn't know what prime number is MH
occasionally if I can cheat a bit it
will start to Guess that that it never
will produce anything out with the data
set because you mind the past the thing
that I'm getting to is I think that
actually current machine learning
Technologies might actually help reveal
why time is fundamental it's like kind
of insane because they tell you about
what happened in the past but they can
never help you understand what's
happening in the future without training
examples sure if that thing happens
again it's like um so I think so let's
think about what large a models are
doing we have the we have the Lang we
have all the internet as we know it you
know language but also they're doing
something else we're having human beings
correcting it all the time those models
are being corrected um
steered corrected
modified tweaked is well yeah but I mean
cheating well you could say the training
on human data in the first place is
cheating well let me human is in the
loop sorry in trou yes so human is
definitely in the
loop uh but it's not just human is in
the loop a very large collection of
humans is in the loop look I to that
could
be I mean to me it's not intuitive that
you said prime numbers that the system
can't generate an
algorithm right
that the algorithm that can generate
prime numbers or the algorithm that can
tell you if a number is prime and so on
and generate algorithms that generate
algorithms that generate algorithms that
I I can start to look a lot like human
reasoning you know I don't think I think
again we can show that on the piece of
paper that sure I think there has you
have to have so this is the failure in
epistemology like I'm I'm glad I even
can say that word let know what it means
you said it multiple times I know it's
like three times now without
failure quit while you're ahead just
don't say it again you did really well
thanks so I but I I think the so what is
reasoning so coming back to chemical
brain if I could basically if I could
show that in a cuz I mean I'm never
going to make an intelligence in in
Camina because we don't have brain cells
they don't have Gile cells they don't
have neurons but if I can make if I can
take a mat a gel and engineer the gel to
have it be a hybrid hardware for rep
reprogramming which I think I know how
to do I will be I process a lot more
information and train train models
billions of times cheaper and use
cross-domain knowledge and there's
certain techniques I think we can do but
it's still missing though the the
abilities of human beings have had to
become true and complete and so I guess
the question to to give back at you and
I it's like how do you tell the
difference between trial and
error um and the generation of new
knowledge I think the way you can do it
is this is that you come up with a a
theory an explanation just inspiration
comes from out yeah and then you then
test that and then you you see that's
going towards the truth and human beings
are very good at doing that in and the
transition between philosophy
mathematics physics and Natural Sciences
where and I think that we we can see
that where I get confused is why people
misappropriate the term artificial
intelligence to say hey there's
something else going on here because I
think you and I both agree machine
learning is really good it's only get
better we're going to get happier with
the outcome but why would you ever think
the model was
thinking or reasoning reasoning requires
intention and the intention if the model
is reasoning the intentions come from
the
prompter and the intention has come from
the person who programmed it to do it so
I'm I um but don't you think you can
prompt it to have intention basically
start with the initial conditions and
get it going where the you know
currently large language models Chad
GPT only talks to you when you talk to
it
there's no reason why you can't just
start it talking but but those initial
conditions came from someone starting it
yes and that causal chain in there so
that intention comes from the outside I
think that there is something in that
causal chain of intention that's super
important I I don't disagree we're going
to get to AGI it's a matter of when and
what Hardware I think we're not going to
do it in this hardware and I think we're
unnecessarily fet azing really cool
outputs and dopamine hits because
obviously that's what people want to
sell us
well but there could be I mean AGI is is
a loaded term but there could be
incredibly super
in
impressive intelligence
systems on the way to AGI so these large
language models I mean if it appears
conscious if it appears super
intelligent uh who are we to say it's
not I agree but I the superintelligence
I want I want to I want to be able to
have a discussion with it
about um coming up with fundamental new
ideas that generate knowledge and if
this if the superintelligence generate
can M novel E from the future that I
didn't see in its training set in the
past I would agree something really
interesting is coming on I'll say that
again if the if the intelligent system
be a human being a chat chat B something
else is able to produce something truly
novel that we I could not predict even
having full audit trail from the past
and I'll be sold well so we should be
clear that it can currently produ it can
currently produce things that are in a
shallow sense novel that are not in the
training set but you're saying truly
novel I think they are in the training
set I think everything it produces comes
from a training set there might be inter
there's a difference between inter
novelty and interpolation we do not
understand where these leaps come from
yet that is what intelligence is I would
argue those leaps
and some people say no it's actually
just what will happen if you just do
cross demain training and all that stuff
and that may be true and I may be
completely wrong but right now the human
mind is able to mine novelty in a way
that artificial intelligence systems
cannot and this is why we still all have
a job and we're still doing stuff and
you know I used chat GPT for a few week
oh this is cool and then it took me two
I had to I well what happened is it took
me too much time to correct it then they
got really good and now they've they've
done something to it it's not actually
that good yeah right I don't know what's
going on censorship yeah so I mean
that's interesting but it will push us
humans to uh characterize novelty better
like characterize the the the novel like
what is novel what is truly novel what's
the difference between novelty and
interpolation I think that this this is
the thing that makes me most excited
about these Technologies is they're
going to help me demonstrate to you that
time is fundamental and unit future is
bigger than the than the than the
present which is why we we are human
beings are quite good at generating
novelty because we have to expand our
data set and and to cope with unexpected
things in our environment our
environment throws them all at us again
we have to survive in that environment
and I mean I like I never say never I
would be very interested in how we can
get um cross-domain training cheaply in
chemical systems because I'm a chemist
and bra the only sen in thing I know of
as a human brain but maybe that's just
me being boring and predictable and not
novel